Ukrainian forces are trying to punch
through the strong Russian defenses as
they continue their counter-offensive
Ukrainian troops are telling CBS news
they are determined to win and Lee is in
Ukraine in good morning
good morning Nate Fierce fighting is
taking place along the entire front line
but experts say we still haven't seen
Ukraine's main thrust
Ukrainian artillery softens the target
this donated German Howitzer fires on
Russian positions
reloads and shoots again before moving
to avoid returning fire
this Soldier says we didn't start the
war but we'll end it after the artillery
the Infantry moves in Winding through
the thickets to avoid detection but meet
stiff resistance and a fierce gunfight
breaks out
this battle took place on the outskirts
of bakmut in the Donetsk region once
known for sparkling wine it's now
Infamous for the wars fierce's fighting
and utter destruction
keep an eye on the assault okay switch
on stop mode operators on the ground
direct the troops beginning with things
there weak but they're getting stronger
in my opinion and these two three months
will be very important for our
independence
urging continued support for Ukraine
defense secretary Lloyd Austin visited
NATO's headquarters we've given
Ukraine's forces important training and
impressive capabilities
but war is fluid Dynamic and
unpredictable anxiously watching
Ukraine's counter-offensive is Igor
kuzmenko he worked for the donax
regional government Exile since Russia
took the area in 2014. are you working
with the government then to implement a
plan for once the soldiers retake don't
yes to bring a government back into
service
talk yes he told us such a plan is being
prepared right now for when the
Ukrainian government returns to its
legal territory are you in close contact
with the military about them taking
Donetsk right now our work is
humanitarian Igor says but we have
departments directly in contact with the
military
defense secretary Lloyd Austin is
echoing what many troops here are
telling us that this fight won't be an
easy sprint but he added the United
States will stand by Ukraine for as long
as it takes Adriana
Ian Lee with reporting From The Trenches
Ian thank you